ده زيت تاريخيه الفوز بكاس العالم للمره
الثانيه على التوالي واضافه نجمه ثالثه
يستعد الديكه لتحدي اسود الاطلس اذ في
مواجهه منتخب مغربي لاستثنائي منذ بدء
المونديال يدرك الفرنسيون ان على منتخبهم
اي يؤدي مباراه استثنائيه
استثنائيه مكنت لاول مره منتخب افريقيا
في المغرب ولم يصل صدفه الى هذا الدور لكن
اظن ان المنتخب
واذا كانت بدايه المنطقه القد ادخلت بعض
الشكوك على نفوس انصار الديه كثيف فيما
يتعلق باستقرار خط الدفاع فان بقيه
المشوار زرعت فيهم الطمانينه فالاختراق
دفاع المغرب الصلب والمتماسك سيعتمد
الديكه على عده اسلحه بينها كيليان مبابي
واوليفيرجي»
مثل ما حدث في نهايه المباراه مع انجلترا
من جهتهم يتوقع مباراه صعبه وهو يتمنون
الا يسقط في الفقه الذي ينوي اسود الاطلس
ايقاعهم فيه عدم التقليل من المنافس
وجمهوره يبدو المفتاح الاول لفك شفره
اطاحه تشكيله
الجمهور المغربي في الملعب لكننا نستعد
لكل الاحتمالات بهدوء وطمانينه وبتحليل
طريقه في خصمنا وبرفع مستوى والاستجابه
لمتطلبات نصف نهائيا المواجهه بين المغرب
وفرنسا ستشهد مباراه داخل مباراه فكليان
مبابي واشرف حكيمي بينهما وشائج صداقه
كبيره اذ منذ نحو عامين يتقاسمان كل شيء
لكن هذه المره لا مكان للاثنين معا في
النهائي الاردني الجزيره الدوحه